hey guys this is the D with max sec and
today we're gonna see if we can hack the
1 + 7 pros and display fingerprint
sensor two months ago we were able to
easily hack the 1 + 60 s in display
fingerprint sensor by using the same
method that we're using in this video
and we also tested the Galaxy S 10
plusses ultrasonic fingerprint sensor
and we were not able to hack it so we're
interested to see if we can hack this
one because it's a lot faster than
before as you guys probably have seen in
different videos it's incredibly quick
so we're curious to see if oneplus
increase the security or if they just
made it faster and it still has the same
issue of being able to get hacked this
right here is our fake fingerprint made
entirely out of Elmer's glue I'll show
you guys how we made this grab some
tinfoil grab a hot glue gun put a nice
little dab right here get your thumb wet
and just put your fingerprint right into
the hot glue wait for it to dry then
grab some Elmer's glue and fill it in
wait for that to dry and as soon as it
dries you can go ahead and peel it back
you guys should really be careful
because if it's dry it can crack very
easily but you peel it back basically
take it off like that and if it's dry
you can also heat it up a little bit
before you try to take it off and you'll
end up with a little fake fingerprint
like that so this guy right here
so before we test the 7 Pro I'm gonna
show you guys how easily it works on the
oneplus 60 you guys can see it's
unlocking with my thumbprint and it's
not unlocking with my index finger let
me show you right there index finger is
not recognized I'm gonna grab my little
fingerprint overlay it use my index
finger and there you go and unlocked
just like that you guys can see it's
unlocking let's move over to the 7 Pro
my thumb is unlocking it index finger is
not recognized let's grab this once
again yeah yeah it is unlocking it it's
working very quickly and basically every
single time I'm not having any issues at
all it is unlocking it so it seems like
although it's incredibly quick on the 7
Pro they did not improve the security at
all so just to show you guys that
there's no
trickery going on here I'm here in the
settings I'm gonna delete that
fingerprint that I have no fingerprints
at all I'm gonna add a new one of my
thumb just like that getting a good skin
okay now let's put in the edges this is
gonna be at one taker almost done there
you go
and there you go
unlocks with my thumb doesn't with my
index finger let's grab our little fake
fingerprint here and okay not working
yet let's see if we can get it to unlock
oh there it goes guys as you guys saw it
unlocked see if we can do it one more
time oh there you go maybe it's a little
special spot on this thing seems a
little bit more secure this time around
it's funny that the last try I have is
actually working oh there you go there
you go
seems like it's almost every single time
now I'm actually wondering if it works
better when it warms up a little bit so
there you have it guys we're able to
hack the oneplus 7 pros fingerprint
sensor basically every time now of
course this is not very practical
because it's going to be very hard for
somebody to get your fingerprint and do
this but if you're very serious about
security you're some kind of top
executive or something just know that it
is possible to hack this in display
fingerprint sensor so going back to the
previous video where we were not able to
hack the galaxy s 10 plus this
fingerprint sensor we think it might be
because it's using a different
technology it's using ultrasonic instead
of optical now of course it's not as
quick as the 1 + 7 Pro is the galaxy sn+
takes a little bit of extra time so
maybe that's why it's more secure and
that's why we're not able to hack it but
Samsung has been improving the speed and
reliability of that sensor that has us
wondering if Samsung lowered the
security of the ultrasonic fingerprint
sensor to make a
quicker and more reliable so if you guys
would be interested in a video like that
hit that like button to show us that
you're interested if you want to see
more videos on the one plus seven pro
we've got two of them right there and if
you're not already subscribed click that
button above this has been AVG with max
sec thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video oh there it goes
guys as you guys saw